exactly 53 years ago tonight a charming
young actress appeared on the show to
receive her second Academy Award for her
starring role in the heiress ladies and
gentlemen welcome to the this two time
Oscar winner and all-time film favorite
Olivia Miss Olivia de Havilland
this night is a memorable one for me and
so was at night 53 years ago much has
changed in our world since then but what
hasn't changed is our love of the movies
and their ability to inspire us and to
help us through troubled times tonight
we are celebrating Oscars 75th birthday
and the great artists who have over the
years added so much to our lives through
their work here are 15 9 of them
Dame Julie Andrews Mary Poppins
Kathy Bates misery
Halle Berry monsters ball
Ernest Borgnine Marty
red buttons sayonara
Nicholas Cage leaving Las Vegas
Sir Michael Caine hannah and her sisters
and the Cider House Rules
George Chakiris West Side Story
jennifer connelly a beautiful mind
sir Sean Connery The Untouchables
Geena Davis accidental tourist
Daniel day-lewis my left foot
Olivia jihad
to each his own
the heiress
Kirk Douglas honorary Oscar
Michael Douglas Wall Street
Robert Duvall tender mercies
Louise Fletcher One Flew Over the
Cuckoo's Nest
Brenda Fricker my left foot
Hugo Gooding jr. Jerry Maguire
Louis Gossett jr. an officer and a
gentleman
Joel Grey cabaret
you
Tom Hanks Philadelphia
Forrest Gump
Marcia Gay Harden Paula
Dustin Hoffman Kramer vs Kramer
and Rain Man
Celeste Holm gentleman's agreement
Angelica Houston Prizzi's honor
Claude Charmin jr. the yearling
Jennifer Jones song of Bernadette
Shirley Jones Elmer Gantry
George Kennedy Cool Hand Luke
Sir Ben Kingsley Gandhi
Martin Landau and wood
Cloris Leachman The Last Picture Show
karl malden a streetcar named desire
marlee matlin children of a lesser God
Hayley Mills Pollyanna
Rita Moreno West Side Story
Patricia Neal HUD
Jack Nicholson One Flew Over the
Cuckoo's Nest terms of endearment and as
good as it gets
Margaret O'Brien meet me in st. Louis
Tatum O'Neal Paper Moon
Jack Palance city slickers
the most senior member of tonight's
oscar-winning actors Louise Reiner the
great Zig fell
the good earth
julia roberts erin brockovich
flip robertson charlie
Mickey Rooney Andy Hardy
Eva Marie Saint on the waterfront
susan sarandon dead man walking
maximilian schell judgment at Nuremburg
Mira Sorvino mighty Aphrodite
[ __ ] spacek Coal Miner's Daughter
Mary Steenburgen Melvin and Howard
Meryl Streep Kramer vs Kramer
and Sophie's Choice
barbra streisand funny girl
you
Hilary Swank coins don't cry
John Boyd coming home
Christopher Walken the deer hunter
Denzel Washington glory and training day
Teresa right mrs. Miniver
and the newest additions to Oscars
family album Peter O'Toole Catherine
zeta-jones Chris Cooper
Nicole Kidman and Adrien Brody
you